thank you very much this is really  a huge honor for us we we really  appreciate this  i still remember as we started the m3  project  now about 10 years ago it was a small  research project  and we never imagined to become as  successful  as it is today and now even getting a  technical achievement award  this is amazing so many thanks  to the academy for honoring our work  today embry is used to accelerate  rendering  across a movie industry but this success  would not have been possible without all  the animation  and visual effects studios that have  adopted our technology  so many thanks to our customers  we also would like to thank the  management at intel  that has supported the project over the  years in particular  jim jeffers jim hurley bill mark and  joe curley and i would like to thank my  family  and in particular my wife eswani for her  love and support  thank you very much  you